the best bloopers are the simple
bloopers the ones where talented
glamorous movie stars are supposed to be
in character and - then they burst into
laughter
maybe they flub the line maybe they
forgot the line entirely or maybe
there's no reason at all
and they just come down with a case of
the giggles here are a few actors who
started laughing during their scenes and
just couldn't stop Eva Mendes the other
guys bill Farrell keeps it pretty loose
when filming the silliest of his silly
comedies the other guys was directed by
his longtime writing partner Adam McKay
and both have an extensive improv
background which means Farrell is
strongly encouraged to riff while
filming
unfortunately for his co-stars they
never know quite what he's going to say
or do which makes it very tough to keep
their composure and stay in character I
had to go to a specialist to get my hips
realigned the doctor said it was similar
to operating on a German Shepherd when
they have a hip dysplasia Brad Pitt
Moneyball it's a serious compelling
movie that's surprisingly riveting given
it's mostly about a bunch of people
talking about baseball and doing math to
figure out which baseball players are
the best investments birth or that dry
office and locker room chatter evidently
made Brad Pitt there were little batty
on the set of Moneyball now you can do
he's never known now he's gonna do it
he's never known now he's going to do
what he's never done he's going around
first she can't take the turn Jimmy
Fallon fever pitch
he starred on Saturday Night Live for
six years and a mastered impressive
legacy of recurring characters and
hilarious bits first Jimmy Fallon's
probably best remembered for his
inability to keep a straight face
through sketches when Fallon graduated
from SNL into movies in the 2000s he
couldn't drop his habit and apparently
lost a lot while shooting the baseball
comedy fever pitch frankly most of the
men I've dated has been pootle I can do
it
Paul wrote and Leslie Mann this is 40
Melissa McCarthy was a delightful
surprise and this is 40 she's a force of
comic energy as she just goes up on
Burton man's characters levying a litany
of hilarious improvised threats insults
and observations McCarthy never cracks
but Rodin man however can't control
themselves and I'm glad your husband
died cuz Europe he probably killed
himself Jonah Hill this is the end the
end of the world comedy this is the end
stars a bunch of Hollywood's top young
actors playing fictionalized versions of
themselves it's a crew of gifted comic
performers with agile improv comedy
skills including Jonah Hill a few
mean-spirited lines he'll improvise
about co-star Michael Cera was so
ridiculous he couldn't keep a straight
face yeah he goes and like put on the
dress in life right he's weird he
competing as pageant wait so he yeah he
like for today you'd never met a real
dude honestly he probably has I know he
has a quite Johnny Depp Pirates of the
Caribbean getting paid millions
suggested like a pirate that's just a
life for Johnny Depp who has starred as
Captain Jack Sparrow in multiple parts
of the Caribbean blockbusters
he's clearly delighted to get to play a
high seas Buccaneer because he has such
a good time he just can't quit laughing
on the set you knew this I did not
you knew it I did not
from
from leaf and it's gonna be okay
Margot Robbie Suicide Squad there was a
lot to laugh at during the filming of
Suicide Squad it's one of the most
over-the-top comic-book movies ever made
with multiple over-the-top villains and
over-the-top costumes with over-the-top
personalities vying for screen time
Margot Robbie played Harley Quinn a
protege of the Joker and the Robbie
befitting the character was quick to
laugh on set if I could see my actual
revision Mila Kunis bad moms the cast of
this 2016 comedy was start with
hilarious people and star Mila Kunis is
no slouch either with eight years of
That 70's Show on her resume the left
afloat fast and furious for Kunis while
making the in samba comedy it didn't
take much for her to get the giggles I
didn't watch an extra you gotta check
out Brad Pitt's new haircut hi then
joining it give it to me thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]